in an oped published this morning ahead
of Biden's National address Ohio Senator
JD Vance urged congress not to use the
war in Israel as a way to push for more
Ukraine funding he doubled down on all
of this during Biden's speech tonight
saying quote this is disgusting he's
using dead children in Israel to sell
his disastrous Ukraine policy to
skeptical Americans Senator Vance of
Ohio is now with US senator great to see
you thank you thank you all right Le
let's talk about this they send hundreds
of billions of dollars there and and I
stated this earlier I think two huge
mistakes why is America why have we not
insisted Europe put up their fair share
of the money because they've not they've
relied on America to put the bulk of
money forward and why did America not
pause and say wait a minute why are we
going into yet another long protracted
conflict because Joe Biden won't allow
Poland to give 28 migs he won't allow
cluster bombs he's trying to dictate uh
how uh at the time zalinsky and Ukraine
would fight the war I'm not interested
in Joe Biden's handcuffing if you're
going to fight a war win the war if
you're not going to fight it stay out of
it and Joe hasn't fought this war to win
it neither as Ukraine at this point
neither is Europe they're not protecting
their own
continent well Sean you you raised a
really interesting point here which is
right now America doesn't need client
stains we need real allies and if the
Europeans aren't going to step up and
actually carry their Fair sh
they're not real allies they're
basically depending on our generosity
and right now uh Sean we just can't
afford it and we can't support the
weapons necessary to fight a two or God
forbid a three front conflict if China
invades Taiwan we know right now Shan
that there are artillery shells the
Israelis need for their operation in
Gaza that we have sent to the ukrainians
why have we allowed our industrial
capacity Sean to get to the point where
we don't make enough artillery shells to
support our friends and given that
reality why is Joe Biden going on
national television and selling people
on a Ukrainian escalation when Joe Biden
is talking about the terrible tragedy in
Israel whatever your view Sean on on
Ukraine it is a separate country and a
separate problem I think what the
president did is completely disgraceful
if he wants to sell the American people
on 60 billion more to Ukraine he
shouldn't use dead Israeli children to
do it it was disgusting it really was
would you what did you want to hear
tonight that you didn't hear because
there was an awful lot that I wanted to
hear um not that I really had any high
expectations I wanted to hear more about
the Americans killed I wanted to hear
more about the absolute brutality and
and Terror committed against Israel I
wanted to hear more uh about Iran's
involvement why why do you think the
president was bouncing back and forth in
a kind of disjointed way tonight
unfortunately Sean I be I think it's
because he has no leadership and he
recognizes that his policies are
responsible for the state of the world
so he had this defensive tone instead of
frankly just acknowledging that he's
been a failure he has to do better what
I would have loved to see Sean one was
The Mention Of China because China
benefits from all of this chaos the
regional conflict in the Middle East as
much as anybody in the world the other
thing Sean is why was Joe Biden talking
about the rise of islamophobia after
September the 11th there are 1500 dead
Israelis and of course there are bad
people in any country who are going to
do things the idea that that
islamophobia is a significant challenge
for this country or Israel right now is
absurd it is absurd you know I've seen a
lot of virulent anti-Semitism that's
what I've seen right everybody here is
shaking their head everyone agrees uh
that's exactly right Sean all right good
to see you my friend thank you tonight
hey Sean here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else